foreign
[Music]
there are rich teams and there are poor
teams then there's 50 feet of crap and
then there's nothing welcome to open my
jobs take this team to the championship
I need more money we're not New York
we're not going to compete with 120
million dollar payroll we've got to
think differently
[Music]
be to buy wins who are you here is 25
players that have been overlooked by
every other team for one reason or
another like an Island of Misfit Toys in
here is a championship team one that we
could afford who's a good the kid he's
the new assistant GM we're gonna shake
things up tell them
do you want me to speak
it's a new direction of the open eggs we
are card counters at the blackjack table
we're going to turn the odds on the
casino you don't put a team together
with a computer Billy adapt die
Billy Bean has come in and tried to
reinvent a system now it's just not
working out
they call it Moneyball
I think that he bought a ticket of the
Titanic
hey daddy do you think you'll lose your
job what like go on the internet
sometimes well don't go on the internet
watch TV talk to people
[Music]
do you believe in this thing or not 100
listen up you may not look like a
winning team but you are one
so
play like one tonight
[Applause]
we're doing something really unexpected
and special and the whole city is
feeling it if we win this team we change
the game for good
it's better work
I'm just kidding
[Music]
look out there
out there is the perfect lamp
you see it
I think so
most people can't
Carol Shelby maybe Leo Coke Ford motor
suppose Henry Ford II wanted to build
the greatest race car the world's ever
seen to win the 24 Hours of Le Mans
what's it take I'll take something money
came by but he can buy speed wasn't
about speed
we need a pure racer behind the wheel of
your car that's Ken miles I don't trust
him an inch we heard he's difficult no
no Ken's a puppy dog
no whatever it is shell no trust me
you're gonna build a car to beat Ferrari
with a forward correct
how long did you tell them that you
needed to 300 years 90 days
this isn't the first time Ford Motors
has gone to war we know how to do more
than push paper do I have Carol go to
war
thank you sir
do you think you can beat Ferrari
we're lighter we're faster
that don't work we're nastier
You're Gonna Make History
you ready I was born ready Mr Shelby hit
it
[Laughter]
I spent the last seven years of my life
living out my wildest dreams
Bianca
Rocky my dad
this is built on their shoulders
[Music]
can I help you let me get a autograph no
I signed an autograph but you get off my
car you'll remember me huh
[Music]
damn you
how long were you locked up 18 Years bro
just got out last week
got to tell you back I know I've been
away a long time but kept myself in
shape I still got gas in the tank come
by the gym
thank you
[Music]
girls what happened with you two I
didn't tell you he was like brothers
I was the best though but I never got a
chance to prove that that's cute
I know what you doing Donnie you don't
always do nothing
Damien's fighting the world he's trying
to hurt people I bounce for you you
think you mad try spending half your
life in a Cell why did somebody else
live your life
I'm coming for everything you
threatening me
something is going on with you
Damien was like family
[Music]
now we passed talking then maybe you
just have to find out
I recognize mine I know that they needed
me yet
I need you to make all your fear
they're called a guilt
let go of whatever was and walk into
what is I feel those chains are breaking
yeah
[Music]
the haters always say Tanya tell the
truth
there's no such thing as truth
everyone has their own truth
I was the best figure skater in the
world at one point in time
call out a clean skate for Christ's sake
do not swear in front of the kids I
didn't swear you [__]
[Music]
you two [__] yet
you need to see a wholesome American
family I don't have a wholesome American
Family who skated like a graceless bull
Dyke it was embarrassed for you my
entire life I've been told I wouldn't
amount to anything
you know what
maybe I would
believe
how do I get a fair shot here we also
judge on presentations suck my dick
I'm playing field I know a guy shouldn't
even be saying his name
Derek the Press wanted me to be the pile
of crap
I never did this
[Applause]
[Music]
what is going on we're with the FBI they
know
what can you tell us about Tonya Harding
I don't know what Tony Hardin are you
her bodyguard
do you ever love you I made you a
champion knowing you'd hate me for it
that's the sacrifice a mother makes she
cursed me
America
they want someone to love
but they want some
I mean come on what kind of freaking
person bashes in their friend's knee
who would do that to a friend
stop that
[Applause]
growing up we all want to know the
toughest skin in the neighborhood was
right I want to know the toughest man on
the planet is
that's what we're gonna find out
friend it's me pop what are you doing
here Tommy's back did he say if he wants
to see me
I'm proud of you Tommy what you did for
that kid in the tank what was I supposed
to do let him jump Tommy Reardon you
saved my life look Brendan the bank has
got to go by the new appraisal figures
you're upside down on your mortgage how
much do you need I didn't come in for
long Frank I was hoping that he would
train me are you serious
we're gonna raise our children in
Brennan you're a teacher you got no
business in the ring with those animals
actually I used to be one of those
animals
I've got to put that down in my
application
there's this big tournament
top 16 middleweights in the world and it
takes all I'm gonna need a trainer for
that much
I got a family to protect everything I
do is for them what's going on up here
Daddy is now a princess
Mom needed you I needed you you're my
big brother you bailed on me I was a 16
year old kid what the hell did I know we
had a choice okay you had a choice
teacher they pulled off a miracle
do this what are you saying I can do
this
[Music]
are we here to win this fight now
because if we're not bro
[Music]
what's going on everybody okay they got
a call said there was trouble in the
house okay yeah okay well you all need
to look around
it's a little wet for practice don't you
think don't the girls have school work
to do
they do their homework tundy's first in
her class Lynn and Isha are too now I
don't even mind you saying we hard on
these kids you know why cause we are
that's our job to keep them off these
streets you want to check on the kids
let's check on the kids we got future
doctors lawyers plus a couple tennis
stars in This House the chances of
achieving the kind of success that
you're talking about is just very very
unlikely okay you're making a mistake
but I'm gonna let you make it
watch them hit a few balls all right so
tell me your names again I'm Venus I'm
Serena
what do you think
I wrote me a 78-page plan for the whole
career before they was even born
these girls so great how come I've never
heard them they're
it's okay they just
didn't like us
it's nervous make a step up
maybe she wanted to take a few more
steps up just get someplace safe
I think you might just have the next
Michael Jordan oh no brother man I got
me the next two
this next step you got to take you're
not gonna just be representing you
you're gonna be representing every
little black girl on earth
they're not gonna let you doubt how
could you
this world ain't never had no respect
for Richard Williams but they gonna
respect y'all
you can walk out there with your head up
you are a champion and the whole world
knows
it's a woman who know how to think yes
daddy ain't nothing she can't do
you want to show them how dangerous you
are
[Music]
Venus and Sabrina
gonna shake up this world
[Music]
Venus Williams who is your best friend
hey Daddy Serena Williams who is your
best friend Venus thank you
thank you
she's my younger brother you gotta help
me finish this taught him everything he
knows you don't want to see where this
fight is
still his training
I have a fight next week and after I win
I'm gonna start making good money so you
can live many more days okay good luck
daddy don't hold your breath Casey bye
baby
you paved streets right yeah I do and
I'm a fighter I heard you were a
stepping stone oh I've had a few tough
fights but the next fight is going to
show who I am yeah and he's gonna lose
that one too so move that Sugar ass
don't disrespect her Mickey Ward is 31
years old he's here because he needs the
money look at the size of that guy he's
got 20 pounds on me Dicky you don't
fight nobody gets paid
I'm quitting Shelly I'm done fighting I
don't need it anymore it's sad that you
let them take it away from you I was
embarrassed I told everybody I was going
to win that fight and get back on track
so it could be in a disappointment
look Mick nobody's got heart like you
you're a very talented fighter I want to
give you a real shot make one last run
of this thing before it's too late what
about my brother he's taught me
everything I know I can't do it without
him well I'll do a respect he's too much
trouble get on the ground right now
for me no more okay
you ready for a title shot not a
stepping stone anymore he's using you
you can't beat me you had a hard enough
time being you and that's why you're in
here
waiting they gotta go why am I the
problem mommy's blood I'm his family
you're crazy I'm the one fighting not
you not you and not you
this is my shot at the title I won't get
another one after this
he has a chance to do something that I
never did and he needs me
okay I see I make his Corner
this is your time I had only come in my
Bluey you don't have to you're making
why he'll make it why
[Music]
you are to death The More Alive you feel
you're James aren't you yes
who's that it's Nikki louder it's just
been signed by Ferrari
look at why he's driving like an old man
right now it's zero incentive why would
I drive fast because I'm asking you
[Applause]
this is an incredible battle between
these two great drivers
next time I'll have you no chance you're
just a party guy that's why everybody
likes you yes I know I'm terrible no
you're not terrible you're just who you
are at this point in your life
more than just being quick you have to
really believe
he's consistent Dependable he put his
life on the line the day they really
mattered welcome to the racing drugs Max
of the decade
world champion Nikki louder trapped in a
searing Inferno of 800 plus degrees
[Music]
talk to me James don't go to men who are
willing to kill themselves driving in
circles looking for normality and what
did your wife say when she saw your face
to drive you just hit the right foot I
feel responsible for what happened
watching your windows races well I was
fighting for my life
you were equally responsible for getting
me back in the cup
at 42 days after his near fatal accident
Nikki louder will race here today
more powerful in the fear of death
is the will to win
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
one beer
you've ever seen you have a daughter no
my daughter she don't like me very much
you should call her
[Music]
what do you want from me I'm an old
broken down piece of meat and I deserve
to be all alone
I just don't want you to hate me
two words
you know the little luck this could be
my ticket back on Top
Gun yeah and that Cobain doesn't come
around and ruin it all
these things that have comforted me
my only face in the broken bones and
bruises I display
[Music]
it hurts I out there I'm really here
a lot of people call me that I never
wrestle again
the only one
day when I'm through doing my thing is
what do you think what do you think
about this
that'll work
[Music]
thank you
you have any idea who I am
some rich guy calls you on the phone
I wanted to speak with you about what
you hope to achieve
good
[Music]
there's a key for you also big house is
off limits okay Coach Dupont has a
vision he would like foxcatcher to be
the official training site for the
national team what's he get out of all
this what are you thinking this is it
this is all that we've that we've ever
wanted Mark you have been living in your
brother's Shadow your entire life it's
your time now
I promise you
I'll give you everything I have I am
Leading Men and I am giving America hope
I spent my lifetime looking for a father
and I've found one in John DuPont
[Applause]
it doesn't matter
Sports of wrestling is a low Sport and I
don't like to see you being low why is
there nobody in the gym yeah no I can't
ungrateful ape
Mark Mark
good
I don't need your help
what's going on with you hey what did I
just say
coaches the father
coaches a mentor
coach has great power on an athlete's
life
[Music]
mark
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
that weird family aren't you we're not
weird we don't like wrestling how do you
know if you've never been I've never had
racked or bleeding before but I'm pretty
sure I'm not a fan of that how about I
shove her head up your ass and then we
can find out
hello my name is
[Music]
it's all fake anyways
sorry about that The Rock we're huge
fans thank you so much what advice would
you give us we want to be the next you
what are your names again my name it
doesn't matter what your names are you
walk around here interrupting the rock
you like you haven't seen the sun in 20
years you like it just stepped out of
Oliver Twist please sir may I have some
more advice so you want some advice
here's a rock to biceps your mouth
thanks Dwayne got it
good morning wrestling nerds well this
is where we see whether or not you get
to go on to WWE this is our short side
hello why do you want to wrestle I'm the
toughest bastard in any room probably
shouldn't swear and when there's ladies
present
sorry Miss sorry about that
I call your name that means you'll be
coming with me to Florida Paige
[Music]
thank you all very much
you have to take my brother no one
deserves this more than Zach I wish you
the best son but this is the end of the
line for you do you know what it's like
to want one thing in life and then your
own sister takes it away from you it was
my dream too
I have no idea who I'm supposed to be
out there you're not just doing this
View
you're doing it for the family
[Music]
Paige I myself have come from a
wrestling family too I know exactly what
it means to you so don't worry about
being the next man be the first you
what it's Dwayne Johnson how are you
prove it
and I'm Vin Diesel mate
I'm sorry
[Applause]
pop an Adam
Sean Junior you clean this room up
before you come downstairs you hear me
[Music]
okay big smile chewy family let me get
it y'all everyone thank your mother for
driving to the store and getting this
thank you Mom thank you Mama
he's been enrolled in seven different
institutions including a gap of 18
months around the age of 10 when he
apparently didn't attend school at all I
tell you most kids with his background
wouldn't come within 200 miles of this
place class this is Mike Orr and he's
new here so I expect you all to make him
feel welcome hi
[Music]
who is that extra big Mike what is he
wearing it's below freezing do you have
any place to stay tonight
don't you dare lie to me
come on was this a bad idea that's the
big deal it's just for one night it is
just for one night right find some time
to figure out another bedroom for you is
mine yes sir I haven't had one before
what a room to yourself I bet
it's already nice what you're doing but
don't be surprised if one day you wake
up and he got
he got here last night tell him to sleep
with one eye open you threatened my son
you threatened me
[Music]
Michael's grades haven't proved enough
that he can go out for spring football
in March
his team is your family Michael when you
look at him you think of me how you have
my back are you going to protect your
family Michael yes ma'am that's Jay
you're going to want to get this
who's the big guy eating with your
little brother
this big brother I think what you're
doing is so great Sandra Bullock hey
you're changing that boy's life
no
please change your mind
[Applause]
The Blind Side
[Music]
do your best Lord to protect other than
that you know what I want there's no use
for me repeating myself
is it done I owe you money no sir I know
your mama I thought you might be
interested in training me I don't train
girls people see me fat saying pretty
tough girly tough Ain't Enough
there's magic of fighting battles Beyond
endurance
it's the magical risk and everything for
a dream that nobody sees but you
[Music]
work in the bag boss I'm not your boss
we have bags working you
little girl tend to be coming along
almost like someone's been helping her
I've seen you looking at me yeah out of
pity don't you say that if it ain't true
if I'm too old for this then I got
nothing
if I take you on I promise I'll work so
hard you don't question me and I'm gonna
try to forget the fact that you're a
girl
now what is the rule
protect myself at all times good find a
man marry him people hear about what
you're doing they life it's you
I got nobody but you Frankie but you've
got me
I made a lot of mistakes in my life I'm
just trying to keep you from doing the
same I know boss he's a good man to have
in the corner yes he is
[Music]
I just want to keep her with me you just
protected yourself out of a championship
Frankie I've seen you romance almost
every day for 23 years the only person
comes to church that much is the kind
who can't forgive himself for something
you're
fight I don't know
about it
he gonna leave me never
[Music]
what's going on with you what's new
how much
[Music]
hate the idea of you downloading by
yourself all the time
drinking
I appreciate it
but it's I'm fine ever since I heard
and I suppose you're wondering why I
called you over here I didn't need to go
where a Bible our basketball coach had a
heart attack the other night they need a
new coach Jack and you know your gifts
is the team any good no the last time
they made the playoffs back when you
were playing
right that's right how many threes did
markets make last year a percentage of
26. I wonder why they're leaving you
open because they don't think you could
hit the ocean from the beach
that show ass bro
[Music]
let's get used to the players what
players
[Music]
keeps my mind off other things yeah
I spent a lot of time hurting myself
I mean a lot of bad decisions
I had a lot of regrets
good
night
[Music]
games online I want you taking that shot
why is that so hard for you to believe
what if you're the best player on the
team
[Music]
I know you're suffering
I just want you to be happy again
because you gotta want it too
[Music]
you guys earned this tonight
thank you